i mean i think it's scary i think i i
think you can see the chaos
coming
uh the the uh people the the assumption
of liberalism is let people argue and uh
and be free freely speak and freely
argue and they'll come to the right
decisions but i i would say when you
know since 2020 we're looking at an
america that is
um is just it's tottering on having
uh you know the the the woke neo-marxist
ideology become kind of like the public
the public ideology of of the state
and if you look you know sort of on on
the edges of the political right like
beyond conservatism i i there's
fast growing um
thinkers i mean
that a lot of the kids are reading uh
who are arguing for dictatorship they're
just saying look the whole the whole
idea of you know the american
constitution has failed and uh and
they're looking to dictatorship
so i i think it's becoming really really
clear
that if we don't start talking about
conservation and transmission and
restoration like a lot and focusing on
it
i i
i think america is in danger and i think
it's in danger of taking like all the
democratic countries with it
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is
one of the founders of the national
conservatism conference president of the
herzl institute in jerusalem and author
of the brand new book conservatism of
rediscovery yoram hazoni welcome back to
the reuben report
hi dave thanks for having me back
it's good to see you my friend i sense
by that background you are not in the
holy land but perhaps a slightly less
holy land at the moment
i'm here in dc i i actually wanted to be
with you in florida but you guys didn't
have like room in the studio for me or
something so
so i'm in dc
it's a very we've been very busy i just
got back from tour you're on the short
list of people i would have been willing
to have here at the house but let's dive
right into the book because first off
i've got it in my hand this is a this is
a dense powerful book full of a whole
bunch of the ideas that you've been
talking about
for really decades at this point but i
want to read just the first paragraph
off the back flap here because i think
you say something very interesting that
i think is the thing that sort of
connects both of us you say conservatism
as we know it has failed while
liberalism was eroding the foundations
of our culture the family the nation and
religion
conservative conservatives adopted the
very principles that ensured their
defeat routinely confused with classical
liberalism conservatism found itself
defenseless before a ferocious
and relentless foe all right now you
know i'm mr classical liberal
i uh i think i helped bring that phrase
back into the american lexicon but you
also know that i have found faults
within the the liberal lens
uh we've discussed them before and we've
discussed them at natcon actually just a
couple months back here in florida
um so
what brings you
well first let me let you define
conservatism and how it's different than
classical liberalism and then we'll go
from
there okay
conservatism puts
conservatism's a an anglo an
anglo-american political tradition
it goes goes back many centuries long
before burke
and it's a tradition that puts
puts the the idea of transmission
and stability of the nation at at the
center
so a conservative is always going to be
asking questions like
have we
uh upheld the
you know the the main principles
traditions that are holding our people
together you know that that can't go on
forever there's always deterioration
there's always things that change and
then a conservative is going to be
looking back when you know when when
something starts to fall apart
um and saying
what can we restore what what what can
we go back to
that used to work that we really need
and are sorry that we've lost
so i think a lot of people are hearing
that and that's pretty clean and clear
that you know there were some
hard-fought things of the past that we
should remember and perhaps bring back
into our daily lives
does classical liberalism not
grab a hold of all of that what's the
what's the problem there
well classical liberalism is something
that um is based on like if you take a
look at the you know like the big
thinkers of of of the enlightenment the
rationalist thinkers of the
enlightenment who
uh who originally designed this
uh liberal
liberalism is a it's a it's a set of
principles that begin with uh every
every human being is by nature free and
perfectly free and perfectly equal
and the the purpose of government is to
is to give the individual to to protect
the rights and equalities that belong to
the individual by nature so the the
entire set of ideas that you know
they're at the basis of liberalism
uh they're they're basically you know
lots of people said this they're
basically they they are a philosophy of
freedom they're very
a
a way of thinking about um
how how do we work it so that people are
maximally
free and unconstrained
and the problem is and this is i i mean
this is
this is something very deep and very
serious that i really think we need to
be talking about
much more
is that uh human beings do not only need
freedom by nature and
if you think human beings only need
freedom then then i think you've got a
mistaken and misleading philosophy
human beings need to be constrained they
they they need to have guar guard rails
and guidelines
they need to to
to to be encouraged to do
um the things that are needed in order
to keep their their society their people
their families
to keep it going
and uh it used to be that um
i i would say after world war ii there
was a very very strong impulse in
america and across europe to say look
liberalism is all we it's all we need
people you know private people will make
the decisions about you know
where the guard rails should be what the
constraints should be
and i uh you know it maybe that made
sense to a lot of people then i think at
this point we've reached the point where
you know we're looking across american
across europe and i i think
i mean i think it's scary i think i i
think you can see the chaos
coming
uh the the uh people the the assumption
of liberalism is let people argue and uh
and be free freely speak and freely
argue and they'll come to the right
decisions
but i i would say when you know since
2020 we're looking at an america that is
um is just it's tottering on having
uh you know the the woke neo-marxist
ideology become kind of like the public
the public ideology of of the state
and if you look you know sort of on on
the edges of the political right like
beyond conservatism i i there's
fast growing
um
thinkers i mean
that a lot of the kids are reading uh
who are arguing for dictatorship they're
just saying look the whole the whole
idea of you know the american
constitution has failed and uh and
they're looking to dictatorship
so
i think it's becoming really really
clear
that if we don't start talking about
conservation and transmission and
restoration like a lot and focusing on
it
i i
i think america is in danger and i think
it's in danger of taking like all the
democratic countries with it all right
so you're hitting on a lot of the stuff
that obviously i focus on and i'm proud
to say that at the end of my first book
don't burn this book i made an argument
related to god and belief connecting
some of the classic liberal beliefs uh
to that because i i saw what you're now
talking about i sort of saw it on the
horizon that we could get to this point
so first do you think is that a flaw in
liberalism or is that a flaw in in human
nature or is that or is there there even
a distinction there in that from say
world war ii till about
i don't know maybe five ten years ago
the liberal order sort of worked right
or i don't want to put words in your
mouth in my estimation it sort of worked
and then suddenly this woke uh parasite
got inside but would you say that it
roughly worked for a certain amount of
decades
well i i think it's been running down i
i
look i think i think 2020 was a shocking
was a shocking year in terms of you know
just
institutions all the way acro you know
from the new york times to princeton
university just
being taken over i think it was a
shocking year and i i don't want to say
that like you know
it was obvious that was going to happen
but i think as i i write in in this new
book i think i think the deterioration
has been
uh
really clear
you know almost a straight line since
you know since the 1960s
uh even the 1940s
by 1960s is when
uh is uh is when there's this final
decision that the united states is going
to ban
um god religious tradition
prayer bible just ban it outright more
or less from you know from schools
across the country
and um
the the theory behind it was was people
said look our our country it's it are we
live in a christian country you know
overwhelming majority of people are
christian we can be you know tolerant
and decent to other people but basically
it's a christian country so we we don't
have to have this stuff in the schools
and um i i think pretty much since then
um
the the the assumption that you could
just take
god in scripture out of the schools
and it would continue to live like you
know on sundays and in people's homes i
i think that turned out not to be true
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell